foreign
[Music]
for Monday January 23rd I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
for two years China has been cracking
down on the power of its biggest tech
companies this has spanned sectors
e-commerce gaming ride hailing but now
officials are signaling their
investigations and Regulatory demands
may be coming to an end
so what has this multi-year Crackdown
done to China's tech industry and how
different will the environment be going
forward
with me to go through this is our Asia
Tech reporter Lisa Lynn hi Lisa thanks
for being here thanks for having me Zoe
these investigations and crackdowns have
been running for some time can you give
us an update where exactly do they stand
now yeah so Zoe there's been a few
developments in China over the last
month that have led investors to kind of
speculate that this long 24-month
Crackdown is finally abated because if
you recall more than two years ago the
Crackdown really began when
the authorities pulled the IPO of and
group which is a financial payments
affiliate of Alibaba and controlled by
Jack ma a really iconic Tech founder so
since then we've seen companies large
and small get hit by fines for various
infractions such as data security or
monopolistic business practices
and overall the industry Crackdown
resulted in like plunging share prices
of these previously really high-flying
and popular Chinese tech companies so
what happened over the last month that
gave investors pause and people
confidence is three things last Monday
when authorities kind of indicated that
a probe into a large internet ride
hailing company called DD was coming to
an end and Didi if people don't remember
it I can refresh your memory they had
user registrations pulled in about 18
months ago when they tried to launch a
huge IPO in the US and at that point
Didi was pointed out to have flouted
data security requirements
so that was a very big one and a week
before the DD announcement we also had
officials with the Central Bank
announcing that the investigations into
ant Group which is the mobile payment
affiliate of Alibaba had come to an end
and that ant had
essentially rectified everything
authorities have found to be wrong and
was ready to get the licenses needed to
operate again and just you know
subsequent to this as well we also saw
some silver lining on the video gaming
front when China began to approve the
release of new video games after it
stopped approving video game releases in
June 2021 so it's a combination of all
these things that have made people just
a lot more optimistic you mentioned some
of the investigations that seem to be
wrapping up and of course this spans you
know different sectors within Tech but
can you remind us I mean how much power
did China's Tech sector have before this
all began sure if you go back to more
than two years ago three years ago it
seemed like
the largest Chinese internet companies
such as Alibaba and tencent had their
finger wrapped around every sort of
Industry possible that you could
digitize and really I think that was the
reason why Chinese authorities began
this Crackdown in the first place so now
since then you've seen tencent unwind a
lot of investments in businesses that
are really very peripheral or not core
to its operations so they've unwinded
States in e-commerce companies for
example and tencent is a video gaming
and social media giant have authorities
in China said anything specifically
about this pullback with China it's
always very difficult to ascertain when
exactly like the end of a Crackdown
would be but most of the statements that
have come out over the last couple of
weeks have been very optimistic beyond
the statements by the Central Bank
saying that the ant group investigation
is over you've also seen the local
government in Hangzhou where Alibaba is
based come out to praise Alibaba for
years of actually adding to the economy
and they recently signed a strategic
cooperation with the company again all
these are just indications that the
chill around tech companies and doing
business with tech companies is
gradually thawing does it seem then like
Chinese officials feel like they've
accomplished what they wanted to I think
in several areas they've definitely got
what they wanted they've broken out the
large monopolies that have existed in
the Internet space and they've also
broken up the power structures that were
behind these monopolies so just before
the ant group investigation ended you
saw Jack ma giving up a controlling
stake in ad group
that's probably one of the signs that
Tech Founders now don't have the same
sort of power and influence they had
over their large Empires as they did
three years ago for example and it isn't
Just Jack ma you've definitely seen
other Tech Founders either give up huge
stakes in the companies in the name of
Charity or simply just sell them off so
you've definitely seen an unwinding the
power Stakes Behind These companies and
when it comes to investment and startups
and various Tech Industries the Chinese
government has definitely accomplished
this aim because you've also seen a
flowering of startups in areas such as
chips Enterprise software biotech all
areas that the Chinese government had
already wanted to divert investment to
but was unable to Because the Internet
consumer space had taken up so much of
that Venture Capital money and I guess I
would point out that even if the tech
cracked down on the surface seems to be
winding down it doesn't mean that the
new normal is
that companies are going to be free of
Regulation or oversight even as the
Crackdown was winding down we've also
seen more cases of the Chinese internet
Watchdog take these small but very
symbolic stakes in Internet and
broadcast companies which essentially
give them a seat on the board and gives
them influence over the type of content
strategies that these private companies
have it sounds like they've accomplished
what they wanted but Lisa at what cost
did it take to get there yes and that's
a great question Zoe because ever since
the tech clamdon has started we've seen
large layoffs in Chinese tech companies
and this has come over the last two
years when job creation and unemployment
numbers among like younger people have
already been rising and last year in
2022 the country's economy and its
growth has already been batted by zero
covet policies and these internet
companies had they been thriving would
have been able to bolster tax revenues
in local government coffers
where they were headquartered of course
should they not have been clamped down
on all right that's our Asia Tech
reporter Lisa Lynn Lisa thanks so much
for joining us thanks again Zoe and
that's it for today's Tech news briefing
for more Tech stories head over to our
website wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The
Wall Street Journal thanks for listening
[Music]